despite strong calls for its
cancellation hundreds of pro-palestinian
activists have taken to the streets of
berlin for the annual alkyds
demonstration which marks the day of
jerusalem usually held on the last
Friday of Ramadan the protest is there
guess what's viewed by the demonstrators
is Israel's occupation of East Jerusalem
the Israeli community in the city held a
counter demonstration and expressed
fears that anti-semitism is gaining
momentum in Germany almost two thousand
people have reportedly gathered for both
rallies it is very emotional to be
speaking to both sides
[Applause]
[Music]
this is where the two gatherings me near
in from one side of the Avenue akin to
the participants of the so-called
Alcott's de March this is an Arabic name
for the city of Jerusalem this
demonstration unites all those who do
not support the policy of the State of
Israel and disagree with Jerusalem
belongs to Israel I'm here to send for
Palestinian people the city's rights
this is how the whole world should be
for Palestinian this is our church my
brother was twice in Gaza to act as a
human shield for the Palestinian farmers
not to be shot by what they call
themselves the rally against the rally
those who support Israel we have been
able to talk to the organizers and to
some of the participants
it's not about criticizing Israel's
about the legitimizing Israel and about
hating Jews when people shout Jews in
the gas chambers
then it's it has nothing to do with
Israel critics it's only about the hate
it is a demonstration against another
demonstration inacceptable anti-semitic
al coots March which also taking place
today in Berlin and we should not
tolerate any form of anti-semitism in in
Berlin and in Germany and this is why we
are here everybody texts to its life is
attacking our way of living and this is
why we have to show solidarity and this
is doesn't have anything to do with
Israel
it is this is completely other
discussion what is the acceptor is to
make Jews in Europe responsible for what
the Israeli government is doing this is
absolutely anti-semitic and inacceptable
my and you despite we have to show
solidarity this is why they are here to
support their solidarity with Jews with
Israel and to show how strong they are
to show it to these people on the other
side of the Avenue the pro palestinian
rallies have spread across the Muslim
world
[Music]
boo
[Applause]
[Music]
you